thank you very much armed with a law
degree and an MBA a D so fair tani had
led a number of young companies and
helped spur on Israel's technology
economy now she runs Facebook's Israel
operations today we have something like
5,300 startups in Israel by the way it's
there's no one country in the world that
has that amount of startups except the
u.s. 1,400 new startups in 2015
1,400 new status women must serve
alongside men in the military here
adhi once hoped to fly jets but because
of the gender restrictions at the time
she ended up evaluating who could become
a pilot she sees the time in the Air
Force as crucial to her career
what's the uniqueness of the female
experience in Israel because of the
military service it must have some
long-term effects yeah I absolutely
think it as women in Israel probably
start their career life with more
confidence with the feeling that they
also can but are we done in Israel in
terms of women taking part no we're not
and I think that in Israel we'll
probably because of the military because
of startup nation because of the culture
I think that we are probably closer to
achieve that but we are definitely still
not there